[Music]  these camels are the last of their kind  and caring for them has been an  important part of this community's  culture for thousands of years  this great big story is inspired by  genesis  [Music]  [Music]  muhammad's community there are 150  swimming camels  caring for the camels has been part of  this family's work for generations  [Music]  [Music]  this unique species of camel is native  to the region and has evolved over time  to survive in this environment  [Music]  [Music]  preserving the tradition of camel  herding has its challenges  new industries have begun to crowd the  region and climate change is damaging  their habitat  to preserve their lifestyle herders like  noir muhammad and his family have begun  selling the camel's milk  [Music]  thanks to this new business and an  age-old partnership the bond between man  and swimming camels will continue for  generations to come  [Music]  you